he is just so disappointed right now and  one really has to feel for him i mean  playing at this hour he's had such a  good run in this event  and peter somewhere it felt like the  quarterfinals was in his grip i mean he  started with the lead and he played a  fantastic game three  absolutely i mean it it looked like  match is over yeah it looked like a  knockout punch  but uh yeah he didn't manage to finish  it  and yeah now vaislavia and luke takes c5  and luke takes h5 he's collecting three  pawns ah besides no it's it's even where  do you put this bishop because b5 rook  b8 rugby  that's it  oh my god  you know everything that's  been with ding this whole past through  the whole pandemic with the situation of  not being able to travel for tournaments  and the situation with not getting the  opportunity to play for the candidates  i just really feel for him